utiliza la propiedad conmutativa de la
suma y voy a subrayar propiedad
conmutativa de la suma para escribir en
forma diferente la expresión 585 y
después calcula la suma el término
propiedad conmutativa de la suma puede
sonar muy sofisticado sin embargo es
algo muy sencillo
significa que si sumas un conjunto de
números no importa el orden con el que
lo sumes siempre tendrás el mismo
resultado así que podemos sumar 5 + 8 +
o lo podemos ordenar como 55 más 8
o bien lo podemos ordenar como 855
siempre tendremos el mismo resultado y
tiene sentido pues es lo mismo tener
cinco cosas de algo y luego añadir ocho
cosas y luego otras cinco que primero
tener cinco y luego añadir cinco más y
por último ocho todas van a dar el mismo
resultado lo podemos probar y dice y
después calcula la suma empezaré
calculando la más sencilla que es la
segunda expresión pues es fácil
identificar que cinco más cinco es igual
a diez diez más ocho es igual a 18
ahora vamos a verificar que las otras
dos expresiones tengan el mismo
resultado
la primera es 58 igual a 13 13 5 igual a
18 también da 18 y la última es 85 es
igual a 13 13 + 5 es igual a 18
todas dan el mismo resultado y esta es
la propiedad conmutativa de la suma que
puede sonar muy sofisticado sin embargo
lo único que significa es que al sumar
cosas no importa el orden en que la
sumamos siempre tendremos el mismo
resultado